let's jump into this news man vladimir
putin
from independent putin tells biden
don't be mad at the mirror if you are
ugly
compare he compares capital riders to
his own descent this is amazing
vladimir putin sought to compare
crackdowns and his political enemies
and the arrest of anti-government
protesters in his country to the events
of january 6 in an interview published
by nbc news speaking with journalists in
moscow mr putin claimed
that the u.s and other countries had no
evidence for allegations of election
interference
ransomware attacks and other malicious
activities for which the west has blamed
russia
or russian-based actors in recent years
he also pointed to the arrests of
hundreds of suspected participants
in u.s capital in the u.s capital right
on january 6 as evidence
that the biden administration or u.s was
targeting americans based on their
political opinions
you guys ready for this one quote did
you order the assassination of the woman
who walked into the congress and who was
shot and killed by a policeman
mr putin said referring to ashley
babbitt a california woman who died
during the riot
after being shot by a member of the u.s
capitol police who was cleared of
wrongdoing in her death
do you know that 450 individuals were
arrested after entering the congress
and they didn't go there to steal a
laptop they came with political demands
said mr putin
the u.s he reasoned was guilty of the
same intolerance for political dissent
as his government has been accused of
harboring putin's government in recent
months has cracked down on an
organization run by alexi navalny
a top critic of the russian president
and requested that a court order
uh that a court order to be classified a
court order it to be classified as an
extremist organization his organization
mr navalny remains in prison after
surviving an assassination attempt via
navaj novacek a soviet-era nerve agent
the us uk and numerous other western
nations have blamed russia for the
attack
which mr putin had has denied we don't
have this kind of habit
of assassinating anybody mr putin said
in the interview with nbc
and this is what you really got you got
to understand the other day
we have uh our friend andreas you may
see him in the cast castle vlogs
he was playing video footage just in the
basement of a normal day walking through
moscow
and it's really interesting when you see
this it's just a video of someone
wearing a gopro and they're walking down
the street in moscow and you can see the
shops and the cell phone stores and boy
does it look the exact same as it does
like walking in a street in new york
whatever i mean i get
i get it the architecture's a little bit
different then you realize
you know a lot of people don't realize
this when you're in russia the news you
hear
they don't say putin is the demon devil
they say that you're
they're going to be hearing very very
similar things to what we hear about you
know in the united states
they're going to be hearing things about
the us very similar to what we hear
about russia
so it's interesting we are seeing a lot
of people who look there's a lot of
people on january 6 we always say it
did stupid things and they're going to
get arrested and charged for it but what
about the insurrection
over the past year that's still going on
to this day that's not been dealt with
and the democrats who support it
putin saying what uh what a lot of
people i think in america don't want to
hear
and what a lot of people haven't
acknowledged yet which is pretty big is
that
what's happening to some of the people
that attended the january 6th event is
absolutely
atrocious there's huge violations of
human human rights there's people being
put in solitary confinement
there's allegations of torture there's
people who can't get lawyers there's
lawyers who are afraid to represent
people
and then putin on the national stage to
the u.s mainstream media
brought this up and and i think he makes
a very fair equivalent
i mean the united states points fingers
at countries that violating human rights
well
let's really look at at all human rights
objectively
and let's let's look at it from a way
where we could actually impact it and
make a difference
putin also went on and called biden a
career politician
those are also very big statements from
from vladimir putin
from the same person who also described
the american political system
as being previously ruled by men in
black suits this is a putin
characterization
of the american political system and i
think there's some merit to that
especially when you look into blackrock
the federal reserve
and all these other multinational
billionaire corporations that really
truly have an invested interest in
getting their policies approved
meanwhile popular policies never do get
passed so
this is going to be interesting because
putin and biden will be meeting
face-to-face
in two days and what's going to happen
i mean this is going to be huge vladimir
putin previously
went up to joe biden on the world stage
and said you know what you just called
me a killer
let's have a one-on-one international
debate no rules
no pre-scripted questions me and you
just talking to the entire world
what did biden respond true tonight's
habit of pressure come on man
i think those are fairly accurate he
didn't he didn't respond just like he
didn't respond to today's question when
he was asked about
calling putin a killer he kind of walked
it back a little bit and then was kind
of stuck for
for 25 minutes again minutes seconds 25
seconds
apologies like he was sitting there for
a long time yeah yeah it almost felt
like 25 minutes personally
with just how long the gap was but but
there this is going to be very
interesting to see how this is going to
be unfolding in the next two days
because tensions between these
these two countries the united states
and russia couldn't be any higher and
the stakes couldn't be any higher as
well
to be fair like hasn't vladimir putin
bounced back and forth between like
president and prime minister or whatever
doing that trick to remain in power
yes he has yeah so you know there's room
for criticism just like he said hey you
got alexis navali we
got ashley babbitt uh and and there's
some you know
let's be honest here there there's
something to intellectually
uh you know entertain here yeah i think
the issue is that
in my lifetime the an american president
hasn't had the moral high ground
to talk [ __ ] to putin i mean that that's
my that's my perspective is that
ultimately is he a bad guy sure has
anyone
ruled our country that has been a good
guy in my lifetime
no quite the opposite no so uh it's
weird because i feel
i still i still hold on to these tinges
of patriotism where i'm like
no no no i have to i have to stand with
my nation
but the truth is when i hear putin talk
about our politicians in particular
i find a lot to agree with we should
criticize all of them if someone
violates human rights
they should be criticized no matter who
they are what they are human rights
should always matter
above politics and sadly we don't have
that in our mainstream system
that is just focused on doing the
bidding of the military-industrial
complex
because when a country that has an
alliance with the united states
that has geopolitical strategy to be
gained by the state department we don't
see any criticisms of human rights
violations then
that doesn't happen but when there's a
goal and there's an
aim there's some oil there's some
natural resources there's there's some
petrol dollar politics that could be
played here oh we're going to be talking
about it non-stop
i think also to be fair back the other
day i can point out you know putin has
retained power for a long time
but what's the difference between the
devil you know and the devil you don't
when we have a political system which it
is the exact same people pushing all the
buttons
they just put a different front person
and it's like oh here's the current
iteration of the neoconservative or
neo-liberal establishment
there it's the same party they all agree
on the same thing in fact the only
difference we've seen in the past
in my lifetime was donald trump and then
the neoconservatives joined the
neolibers and formed the
the like this outright uniparty which we
just jokingly
referred to the unit party before
ultimately just said okay we're all on
the same side we don't like trump and
we're gonna do everything in the power
to stop him
i i don't i don't see a big difference
to be completely honest i don't i don't
see a huge difference either and
uh hans herman hopper actually argued
that that monarchy was superior to
democracy for
exactly what you just described that you
have first off you have consistency but
also
you have a guy who is committed to the
long-term
success of his nation because he
realizes he's going to be there for a
while
and with putin you know he's like i'm
going to be there for 20 years i'm going
to take this seriously just
for the record not advocating for
monarchy i'm just saying that
there has been an argument made yeah but
but what you said in the beginning of
this broadcast with people walking in
moscow looking exactly at the people who
walk in new york city
uh you know the people are the losers
here the real winners are the military
industrial complex whenever we see these
two heads of states clash
and we saw a very serious clash point
just a few weeks ago there was massive
troops uh building up on the ukraine
russian border
there was massive u.s nato forces being
sent in there was war games tensions
were
really high who won who benefits off of
that larger geopolitical conundrum that
is ukraine right now that is a proxy war
that is happening right now that people
are dying in right now as we're speaking
who's winning
not the people the shareholders the
missiles martin
lucky martin and exactly boeing yeah
yeah you get it
yeah because the the people like if our
government screws up and then our
country suffers from conflict and debt
those those shareholders those those uh
you know executives
they can cash out that currency to any
other currency they want and jump ship
yeah that's what they're doing it's it's
they're they're profiting off our backs
they're extracting value from our system
and they're playing with countries that
are proxies whether it's yemen whether
it's syria whether it's ukraine and
they're playing with real life
and a lot of people die from this
ukraine joe biden just also announced
that ukraine quote
must clean up their corruption before
joining nato
that's another backstep to again a very
hard line policy said that he just said
it's the same thing they've been saying
going back five six years and when you
look at donald trump donald trump was
the first president to give
lethal aid to ukraine which absolutely
uh angered russia and also escalated the
situation
now we're seeing a bigger escalation on
top of all of that with joe biden
calling him
a killer he's now trying to walk back
those statements biden's also blaming
him for the
hacking ransom attacks that have been
happening here and another big aspect of
this story that people are forgetting
the the ransom hacking attacks are
linked
many times to nsa spying tool kits
that were paid for by american tax
dollars and were let loose on the
internet
the tools used for these ransom attacks
were created by the nsa
and now the mainstream media along with
joe biden are saying it's russia
when even intelligence agencies in the
united states are saying no no it's not
russia there's no way to find out
because it's online this is one of the
craziest things the daily mail kept
saying all these hacks were russian
linked russian linked
and i'm looking at these articles and
i'm like there's no evidence for that
and then joe biden himself comes out and
says
it's not russian linked and then he said
it is russian he said it might no no
it might be people in russia exactly but
not the russian government
not the country itself just individuals
yes and and now he's been asked about
this and putin responded
and he's saying where's the evidence i
want to see the evidence are you going
to hold me responsible for black lives
matter as well
those are literally putin's statements
today
the democrats have been accusing russia
of propping up these these facebook
pages and putting money into black lives
matter
as well as right-wing groups for years
now so yes they are blaming him
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you